a little bit of introduction so I'm a
software engineer at Earth and I'm
really excited to show you what we have
been working on for the past previous
months
so just to indulge my curiosity could
you please raise your hand who has ever
used Apache Kafka in their development
okay
so we have a knowledgeable crowd
um and could you please raise your hand
if you have already tried out at least a
bit of fast Kafka
okay
great today we'll possibly enlarge that
number
um so fast Kafka is a library that will
hopefully give you the ability to
quickly develop test and document the
applications for connecting to Kafka
topics
so let's start with our motivation why
we did it
so we developed a churn prediction model
which
that's just that it predicts and we had
to somehow deploy our model and you if
you already haven't figured out from
from the name of the library we are big
fans of fast API
and um we wrapped our model in a simple
get and fast API does everything else
for us so it handles the message routing
it handles the input data it handles the
output data
but
there was a problem so a customer came
to us and they said they have their data
stored in Kafka topics so we need to
find a way to connect our model to Kafka
and we wanted to do something like this
after some exploration there was no
library that was able to do something as
clean as this
so
we decided that we need to have this
ability to easily write code
to have the stability to have automatic
documentation generation and hopefully
to have a high performance Library
we didn't find anything that satisfied
all those needs so we used pedantic and
we built our decorate decorators on top
of air Kafka and to generate the
documentation we used AC kpi so
combining these three things mainly
we've built fast Kafka
so let's go through consuming
so you can see or we have developed
something that looks quite like Fast API
so you create your application and with
the decorator consume uh you can
decorate your function which will
consume from the input data topic and
then decode the input messages that are
arriving in Json into into python class
so if for any reason you would like to
use any of the advanced options with air
Kafka we have exposed them all in our
consume decorators so if you want to do
some Advanced things you can always
override the underlying AO Kafka
consumer
then we got our first feedback so people
liked it but they needed some other
other support to test so they didn't
like the Json only Json encoding and
decoding so we did just that so right
now as a default you have decoding of
Json formats but if you want to use Avro
you can always Define that in the
consume decorator also you can pass a
custom function that decodes bytes and
it will inject the decoder message into
your function but that's a bit more
advanced for now
so let's go in the same way through
producing
so we wanted to also have a producers
endpoint and to look like this so we
implemented it and it does quite simply
so the producers will do all the
background work for you it will connect
this function to a topic and it will
decode the prediction into a Json and
when you decorate your function with the
Kafka producers as a side effect of
calling these two predictions function
The Returned value will also be sent to
a Kafka topic
if you want to encode your messages in
any other decoder we support average
default but you can always Implement
your own
next big thing for us was we had the
date of customers split in parts and we
wanted to be sure that all the data for
one customer is contained in one
particular partition and in Kafka this
is sold by using keys when producing
messages to topics
so
we did a simple
implementation so if you want to use
Keys you just wrap your returned value
into a Kafka event and Define the key
that you want to use you can Define any
Dynamic key you want you just needs to
be in bytes here it's Mikey but or you
can use the score you can use anything
from your message so it's up to you
um next thing we wanted to be able to
test our app
so this we've designed something like
this so you have a tester class to which
you pass your Kafka
and the tester class creates mirrors of
consumers and producers so where your
Kafka app is producing the tester can
consume and vice versa so where your app
can consume the tester can produce
yeah
to check if everything was sent we also
create mock-ups that you can assert and
check if you gained any messages to your
topics
and lastly uh tester runs an instance of
Kafka in background
but our next
feedback was that you really don't want
to use real Kafka in the background
because the startup and the teardown of
of a real broker really takes much time
and for each test the tests would take
enormously long to reproduce
so
we took some time and we we've
implemented a fully functional Kafka
broker that is running in memory and it
has a fast setup and they're done it's
like under a second it's instantaneous
and it reroutes your consumers and
producers to this in-memory broker and
by using the tester as a async context
manager you will get no side effects
from the tests in between
so it doesn't work as it runs an
instance of real Kafka but it runs an
in-memory Kafka mock-up
but what if you want to use the real
Kafka in your test so for some
integration tests or you really want to
be sure that everything is working as
it's supposed to
we didn't toss the code that we
developed but we've extended our testers
so you can use local Kafka or you can
use local Red Panda Brokers to test your
application if you're really sure that
you're fine with long startup and tear
down but you want to be sure that
everything works completely fine
after that when you have your
application generated and tested you
would possibly want to generate some
documentation for it
so fast Kafka comes with a CLI so when
you install it you get fast Kafka docs
command with which you can generate and
serve the documentation in Asic API
format so to generate will generate a
yaml file which you can copy paste and
use on the AC kpi website
but if you want to don't want to use
that you when you serve the
documentation you get something like
this so you have your subscription or
consumers documented so we are reading
from input data and also we have the
example Json example of what is located
and what the consumer will consume
also you have your producers
documented and you have examples of what
they will possibly produce
lastly you have the title of your
application and also a list of all the
servers that you have defined that your
application can connect to
if you want to use the GitHub actions to
quickly generate the documentation of
your application we've prepared also a
GitHub action that will when you when
you use it generate the documentation
publish it on GitHub pages
next thing to use the application we use
the faskafka Run command
so you you pass the application or a
application.pi file that contains the
Kafka app symbol
and quite simply you just run this
command and it should start up your your
application in another process
if you want to have some horizontally
scaling
you can Define the number of workers so
this will clone your application and run
it in the amount of threads that you
want to run it
so this is something we are quite proud
of this enables us to quickly increase
the throughoutput of our application if
they are written correctly
next thing we want to see how fast our
application really is
so we've designed a
app.benchmark decorator
which you can use and you can decorate
your application it will Benchmark your
your endpoints and write out into the
logs the quickness of your your
consuming and producing functions
so after doing some some initial
background
benchmarks we wanted to find out how
much overhead we really put on on a
Kafka
so this is the worst case performance
penalty we are not using we're not doing
any advanced processing in the uh
consuming and producing functions we're
just encoding and decoding a simple Json
and our Kafka is quite optimized so
anything we did uh reduced it by 30
percent but in real life cases if you
would do some some Computing inside your
uh consuming and producing functions uh
this would quite quickly drop to to
below 10 or possibly close to zero
percent
so some future steps
before that
um you can see that we are quite active
on GitHub so it's five of us and you can
see that we have on average at least one
pull request daily and we are working on
a two-week release cycle so every two
weeks you will get a
minor minor release that almost
definitely has some new new uh
additions in the features feature domain
for for our application
what we plan to implement in the future
months
is
we want to add transactional logic so at
the moment when you consume the message
you automatically commit the offset that
the message has been consumed and if
your application for any reason crashes
that offset is already committed and
you will lose that message
but we want to add The app.process
Decorator which will combine your
consumers and producers and if you if
you don't get the desired outcome of
your function so if it doesn't uh
doesn't go completely we won't commit to
the offsets and you won't lose the
messages
next thing we want to add support for
other messaging protocols such as
rabbitmq this has been requested
some some time from from the Reddit
users and right now we are building a
top of a Kafka but we also want to
support libraries like confluent or
python Kafka so that you can choose
which one do you want to use
um and yeah we want to do the
performance improvements so we are
planning to possibly reward very right
our consumers and producers in Rust to
to enhance the speed of our producing
and consuming
and last but not least a lot of the
features in the past few months have
come from the community feedback at
first we did something that worked for
us and implemented the features that we
needed but as you as you saw with the
Avro and the startup and the teardown of
the tester
what you request is our Command so we
would really be happy to hear more from
you and to find out what can we do to to
make fast Kafka work for you
what's important for us we are actively
looking for collaborators
um so you here you have a QR code which
leads to our GitHub page
and if you would like to collaborate
with us on
constructing a better fast Kafka
application we will be delighted to hear
from you
and also in the past few months when we
did the release we've seen that we are
quite star grading so we are checking
our GitHub every day for for new stars
so we would like if if you like our our
application please star and more more
importantly comment and join the
discussion of how to make fast Kafka
better and also here you have but you
can find also on our GitHub band and in
our documentation you have a Discord
link so if you want to chat with us or
or discuss collaboration please contact
us here
so that's pretty much it and I'm ready
for questions
[Applause]
yep
yeah I can hear you
and I have a bit hello
we actually do something
very it's nice to see that someone has
the same idea we have we developed our
own decorators in the same style
the biggest performance penalty was from
deserializing into my Landing
perhaps
to disabled by identical correlations or
the thoughts that serialization yeah so
is there any possibility of disabling
pedantic
pedantic validation
to this serialize quickly at the moment
no but yeah it will be planned soon the
first thing we wanted to do is
if you want to just put out bytes and
consume them and do any of your thing
that you want to do this is like planned
in the next release it's it's not a big
issue but yeah the disabling of of
validation is is quite a good idea so
this is something we will plan quite
soon
at the moment we don't have that option
but yeah
any other questions here
here I was thought oh
that was talking about like so someone
online asked did you do a comparison
with files
so we've heard about Faust but uh The
Benchmark was so our Benchmark decorator
was implemented uh in the previous
release so last Friday and we did the
benchmarking over the weekend so we
wanted to just be sure that we didn't
completely ruin our Kafka by by our work
but we plan to do the benchmarks in the
future
someone else asked do you provide
integration with stock SD or similar
things
with
start SD
like for Matrix monitoring this kind of
no not yet not yet okay and how up to
date is the underlying Kafka client
implementation
for example AIO Kafka is based on Kafka
python which hasn't had a release for
two years
uh yeah so we are quite familiar with
that issue so uh at first well one of
the
one of our needs was that the library is
well maintained and it's uh quite funny
that we've built on a library that it's
uh that is not quite well maintained but
so we do have a plan to to re-implement
our consumers and producers uh and to to
disconnect disconnect ourselves from the
air Kafka we are using the latest
version but yeah it has this this
mentioned issue
um
so uh yeah our plan was to to put it on
on his two feet uh as soon as we can so
we needed to uh use an existing library
but the plan is to have everything
in-house so that we are sure that
everything is up to date
but we are aware about the issue of
fastcraft of uh python Kafka and uh
Kafka cool
so also like someone also asked can I
run multiple in memory Kafka instances
in parallel to paralyze the test
um well the in in memory uh in memory
broker is like simply a class instance
object in Python so you can most
definitely run it in parallel so
multiple tests running in Peril don't
have any effect on each other this was
one of the reason why we did it because
if we start up and shut down multiple
kafkas and we need to handle the ports
it really is quite a mess so Dean memory
broker can be can be run in parallel
okay and
and last question
how did you actually
achieve but I think this is previous
things yeah so so this pretty Bruins
weren't achieved or we are a bit a bit
slower with the overhead but we plan to
achieve speed improvements in the future
okay yeah I guess if there is that's it
if no question come true anymore and is
there any question from offline
participants
okay yeah maybe
um
do you have to plan to support protobuf
messages or just just buy it as messages
and do I also get the key as a consumer
okay uh yeah uh when you're consuming at
this moment you just get the message
but we
this is just because we are not passing
into into your function we in the
background we have the information about
the key and the partition and everything
else
so it's it's more of an like two hour
issue to to just pass it into your
function and then deploy it so we need
to add it into release uh and uh yeah
when we when we get the feedback that
it's necessary we are quite happy to do
it quickly
so far I've seen that the messages are
kind of independent in the way that
they're processed so it's just about
processing a message but if we have a
scenario where we actually care about
the order of the messages across
multiple partitions or across even
multiple topics is there any uh thought
about this in the future or currently
as far as I know if you care about the
order of the messages you need to have
them in the in the same partition
so you can sort it with the key at the
moment the messages like in this most
simple form the the functions consume
message by message but like Nothing is
Stopping You to have some some Global
list or a dictionary or something that
tracks all the messages that came in so
in in its nature the consumes and
produces function are just python
functions and you can treat them as that
and then you put on the decorators and
they just get called when the messages
come in and they they get produced into
topics
so yeah
um any more questions here
okay it doesn't look like it and someone
asks you
what's your expectation for pedantic 2.0
and yeah yeah we are we're building on
top of it so we are quite happy to hear
that it's going to be I think they said
50 times faster we'll see but yeah we
are
eagerly expecting it
okay
so thank you so much for the very
interesting talk and we will end here
Escape him and laugh out loud